New Year's stream started. Nicholas, Big Nick, Pigolas, FFW as
I've heard him be called by these about.
>> THERE'S LIKE SOME OF THESE SMALL commentary people and
they will say, "Oh, we love Dan. We love Dan. Dan, we love that
guy." But like they do not love me. Augie's just screaming, "IT'S
TOTAL DESTINY DEATH. IT'S TOTAL DESTINY
OKAY, kick.com Augie, AugieRFC.
See what he's got here. What What was Augie doing?
What was Augie up to? Can somebody explain to me why Willie hates
Chud?
Cuz he hated Chud before the doxing video came out.
Um because Chud literally just supported people asking questions.
But I don't know if I ever understood
Why did he hate Chud? And then Turkey Tom probably hates Chud
because of the New Year's stream.
And
now we know why Nick hates Chud.
But what what happened with Willie? Did Chud Willie for the Destiny
stuff, too?
I mean, I Willie but Willie didn't mind my coverage of it. He
watched my coverage of it. I'm sure he didn't like it but he
was still friendly with me afterwards. So it couldn't be because
of
Willie hates Chud because Chud tricked him. >> never say
they have a problem with you to your face, Augie. That's the
problem. Look at what they did to Chud.
They If they had a problem with you, they'd never say it to your
face. That's the problem with them. >> to getting into
a hostile debate but Chud didn't.
A hostile debate? Oh, with Chud? Oh, did Willie and Chud debate
each other and then it went bad? It was on Chud's stream. Okay,
I never even knew that that even happened. So that's I guess
what explain that. So they had a hostile debate and then Willie
just hate It was Willie justified I mean, I'm asking this question
sincerely. I can make assumptions that obviously Willie was like
a or something like that, right? But I don't know.
Did Chud Willy?
And about once and then All this business with Nick, okay? Nick
wants you to believe that I had some crazy take
Chud said quit it on Tommy cuz he was rambling about nothing.
No, about the turkey Tom thing. Wanted to make a bunch of jokes
about Oh, I just realized that watching Augie's chat is actually
going to be really a window into some Nick fan's
Right? Is it not? I feel like that's where you will see some
Nick fans like kind of cross over and you'll see what they're
saying in
And it would be interesting just to see how they think the whole
like timeline
Cuz they certainly seem to hate me talking to Beckett, right?
>> cuz I didn't cover his response cuz I was on vacation.
This all goes back to the New Year's stream. That's the reality
of it. How much of drama came off of the New Year's stream, bro?
How much drama came off of the New Year's stream, dude? >> I wanted
to do another New Year's stream with the same people
uh this I guess last year, but That's another That's another
stream that I that I thought would be really awesome in my own
mind, but I just yeah.
>> I think the New Year's stream would be better now that
everyone hates each
I will say this. Who rejected it? Again, I didn't even send the
offer out cuz I mean, you know the answer, but
I will say this, right?
I was the only person, I think me and Chud were the only people
that came out unscathed. Everyone else just got m- over and over
and over again. [laughter]
Dude, this is the thing.
Just [__] up cuz Augie in a lot of ways kind of started
that combo, no?
game. You got to know how to play it, dude. You got to know how
to play the game, dude. Is Dan still here, by the way? I love
him.
So, BEFORE THE NEW
>> THERE'S LIKE SOME OF THESE SMALL COMMENTARY people and
they will say, "Oh, we love Dan. We love Dan. Dan, we love that
guy. But like they do not love me. Nicholas, Big Nick, Pigelus,
FFW as I've heard him before. [laughter] Who is watching?
Literally though. Dude, did Chud come out unscathed if he's in
deep [__] from it? Even if Oh yeah, I guess now he's
unscathed anymore. It's just me, dude. I'm the only one that
survived for now.
Oh, terrible term. Okay. He didn't want to talk about the Destiny's
off and I was fine with that. I was cool with it. >> By the
way, guys,
>> I just about that term.
I think What is it? Wait, what is it? What is an FFW, Augie?
Wait, Augie, you're the streamer. I'm not really tapped into
all this drama stuff. Augie, what's an FFW?
I've heard of like DFW, Dallas-Fort Worth. Is there FFW? Is there
somewhere else? Fort Worth? They didn't want to talk about it.
Fair enough. If they didn't want to talk about the Destiny stuff,
I understood that Tom was in a position where he's kind of sitting
in his orbit and all this [__] And I was like, "Okay,
whatever, right?" And I Nicholas maybe had some wind of like
some of the stuff that was going on behind the scenes. By the
way, I swear there's a there's an emote in Augie's chat and I
wonder if Nicholas knows about this. I got Augie
Hold on. Is there Hold on. Could May I don't know if it translates
between chats or where they put it. Hold on. This one right here.
Augie RFC Fatty Kirk
The name of the emote is Augie RFC Fatty Kirk. And if I'm not
mistaken, that's Charlie Kirk's face photoshopped onto Nicholas
DeOrio's face.
does Nick know about Fatty Kirk in Augie's Kick chat? Augie RFC
Fatty Kirk
I'm not joking. I just put it in my Kick chat. You can all see
it, okay? Augie
Fatty Kirk. Hold on. Let me Let me pull this onto stream. Just
I don't want to I want this to be like slightly clippable for
somebody cuz cuz I I just want to
Is Nicholas aware of this?
This is AugieRFC Fatty Kirk right here, okay? This this this
AugieRFC
Fatty Kirk.
And then I believe that's Nicklas.
Unless I'm Unless I'm incorrect on this, I do believe that's
Nicklas.
>> We carry the flame. Anyway, I thought that was funny.
But then he brought it up on stream and then people started saying
stupid things about it. And me >> Okay, okay. So, I hear
this take consistently, which is that Chud brought up the Destiny
conversation
um
when nobody wanted to talk about it.
And basically he cornered Tom and made Tom look really bad and
for basically farmed him for content because Tom couldn't say
what he knew at the time. None of us could.
I'm trying to remember, is that
how that happened? Let me look up the uh
the New Year's stream.
I'm actually going to go back uh down memory lane. So, I had
this argument with Nicklas. I didn't want to argue over this
with
But I thought I had a point at the time. I'm pretty sure I had
a point. And I I let it go cuz I was like Okay, this guy's like
super Like I could tell Nick was totally
He was like fuming when he joined my stream when me and Aiden
were debating
And Nick was furious about this. And this is one of the things
that when the Willy thing happened, this is why he totally burned
me. Cuz he he didn't like that I said this about him. But I was
like, "No,
they didn't have more information than like Chud or something."
I I just wanted to defuse.
And now that I think about it, now that I've like argued this
with a couple people, it's like, "Wait, the stuff Tom was arguing
was totally ridiculous. Like about Melina and [__]
that was all stupid. And that didn't require any of the information
that that Chud had in private at that point in time.
like any information Chud had had nothing to do with the Melina
conversation, which is what 95% of this [__] is.
Let me check that.
What was it? So, that was like Nick's point. Now, I do think
I think I got [__] in this cuz I do think Chud said
he'd shared this information with them.
And I'd seen something that indicated to me that it was before
the stream, but I might have also misunderstood. We have to go
back and see.
But, it doesn't matter because none of the information about
the Pxie stuff was relevant at all. Who brought it up first?
He just didn't
How did this conversation go down? Cuz I don't really remember
it that well.
All I remember was we all decided we weren't going to talk about
Destiny because at the time we all knew
about him that couldn't get leaked otherwise it would harm the
victim story or something like that. And then
somehow it got brought up and I don't remember who knew what
everyone else
Let me see here. Dude, I keep I keep seeing people in chat going
Chud Chud is like crying right now. Chud sounds like he's about
to cry.
Destiny was talking to No [__] one >> Okay,
here we go. You know the clip? But, you know the clip, right?
Where he's like
>> He's like what
Destiny was talking to No [__] one >> Okay,
here we go. You know the clip? But, you know the clip, right?
Where he's like
He's like what
He just couldn't even like stand behind it. That was That was
a debate, bro. Check. I'm basically a neo-Nazi and he's one of
my real takes. >> Yes. No, he didn't. What he said No,
that's not true either. >> He did it on Bunti's stream.
Yes, he >> No, let me What Yeah, that's why Destiny called
Bunti an inbred.
You're going to cover Destiny? Wait,
I brought all that [__] I That was Augie. I knew
it was Augie. >> all those earlier mentions of Destiny
were just like memes. Like we weren't actually talking about
him yet. >> on my feet. I was ready to cover it. I'm just
like I don't know what's happening here. So, I'm not touching
this. >> Oh, you're going to cover Destiny? I had the Destiny
stuff all pulled up and I'm like I don't know. Wait. Or was Nick
pulling it up? When I say the Destiny stuff, chat probably thinks
I was going to pull up him talk like the video of him sucking
on camera. But no, like the I'm just waiting to see if he ever
responds to anything about it. It was like sort of me and Nick
that brought it up, I think. The clip yesterday. I the the Wek
one. The Wek one. Chud didn't run with it. I swear Chud doesn't
run with it. All Chud does is basically he lets them talk until
these people are out until these people start saying things that
he doesn't agree with. And then when they start saying things
he doesn't agree with, he has to differentiate himself, right?
It was terrible. You're a piece of [__] What the
[__] is it me? Why do I never get accused of this
then? That was brutal. What's happening? But I just the thing
is like you just you just don't know. There's no way to know.
NICHOLAS DE'ORIO? OKAY, AM I CRAZY? I THOUGHT IT WAS UH AND um
this is my specula before I make a comment on this, this is my
speculation. I'm saying this as a fact. But when all those DMs
got leaked, I just kind of assumed in my mind that that was obviously
revenge
Dude, what the [__] Come out with the revenge tape
knowing
knowing that it's accurate.
Oh my god.
Okay, it's not technically revenge but
it's it's something close. It's just funny how
if you I hate to say it, okay? I don't actually hate to say it.
It's obvious though. You just assume the worst possible motivation
and intentions for Destiny, you're just accurate like 95% of
the time, okay? That's just facts. Unfortunately, that's just
facts. And Augie was the only person there with an accurate read
on Destiny. Well, no, Chud probably did too. But Chud knew knew.
Augie didn't know. Augie just had intuition. And his intuition
was Destiny's a total piece of [__] Yeah.
>> Augie didn't know. Augie just had intuition and his
intuition was Destiny's a total piece of [__] So,
probably I don't know, probably some non-consensual [__]
happened here. What the
Why do I not get any [__] for this? This is crazy.
Wow, Augie, what a brave take. How did you come to that conclusion?
Wow, dude, I am like actually a massive piece of [__]
here. You said that when it happened, I think.
Wait, there's no way I'm actually the one that fully brought
it up. Destiny So, here we're mainly talking about like Destiny
King. And then ball blacks comes
Smaggle. Okay, so we're obviously talk just talk about stupid
[__] The only time Destiny is brought up and it's
like
Just go just go like eight lines up and >> Wait, serious
conversation a minute before before we get into this.
Oh, god. Oh, this photo this photo on my other monitor is kinetic,
certainly. >> She's not Melina. She's not Melina. It's
What's the
That was a joke for the record. That was a joke.
Nick, even though
Dude. Dude, Nick Nick makes a joke to the non-consensual images.
Let's go. He didn't know they were non-consensual at the time.
Although, wait, no, he did. Oh, actually that makes it kind of
[__] up because Melina had said as
Oh, that's actually way weirder.
Cuz Nick That is a weird comment, isn't it? Because technically
you could say, well, Nick didn't know stuff was non-consensual,
but actually the things that he cut up and had ready were the
clips of Melina saying it was
And he made that joke right there.
A lot of great stuff on this channel. >> No, I don't
I brought all that [__] I I had all that [__]
on my feet. I was ready to cover it. I'm just like, I don't know
what's happening here. >> Nick brought up Melina. Why would
he say
Or he just dropped the Melina reference? Well, at this time the
Melina stuff was public though, right? So The Melina stuff was
public and publicly
>> Nick brought Was there anything before that?
Or we talked about Melina before this, bro? I'm No, no. Nick
just brought that up cuz he thought it was funny that there was
like a woman on his other monitor, right? >> detective
work. Sorry if this is boring as [__] brought up
Destiny on the New Year's stream and you No, he didn't play audio
from a leak. No, no, no, no, no. >> kept Bowblax from apologizing.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. They have
a video on the other screen or something and it's like a goofy
joke. praising. Your joke Oh, he plays the Melina clip later,
yeah. >> any other [__] still >> the
funny thing is, I think I've made this comment before, right?
It's a clip from Melina's stream that he plays >> I was
a mega piece of [__] on the
Cuz I was also [__] stirring with Kinetic Kel, too.
I've been protected
for some reason.
I don't know why. I mean, I'm glad.
I didn't get any [__] for the New Year's stream,
even though I was like the worst offender, looks like. What the
[__] This is a crazy thing to learn about.
This is boring. Is that an ins- Is that an ins- Oh, I'm not I'm
saying I'm not reporting that as like, oh, this was confirmed,
but I'm just saying like in my mind, I'm like, yeah, this clearly
must have been like I mean, we're talking about it in regards
to The The guy that The guy that did the hack and released it.
That's that's like explicitly revenge. I think there's another
term for it. If you send that to someone
No, no, no, but it's like it's No, no, it's called something
else. It's called like the sharing of non-con- the non-consensual
sharing of intimate images because it's not being done for the
intent, but it's still bad to do it. Is it Is it Is it Is it
Is it Is it Is it Is it Is it The participants in those videos
were knowledgeable this was being shared at all is the question.
Yeah. >> Right. But >> Well, I doubt they were. I
mean, I doubt they were. Unless she was a [__] brain
dead [__] or whatever.
Okay. So, that's the place where Chud says that Chud knows that
they weren't. That is a unique piece of information that Chud
has that he takes a strong position
that, you know, Tom was friends with Destiny, Nick was like kind
of friendly with Destiny, and the strong position Chud takes
there is based on true knowledge, not fake knowledge. Like not
not his assumptions. Sorry, not even fake rather it's Sorry,
it's proof he's seen the Pixie
Is it the Pixie Erudite DMs? He's seen like the Pixie Erudite
DMs. Like he knows No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. The rest of
them claim and I don't know I would actually this would be a
great thing to get from Chud like conclusively on the record.
I actually should ask him about it. When did you let them know
this other information? So, I'm being told no Moody Morgan. I've
been told no, they didn't have that information before the stream.
They knew about the Melina stuff. They knew about like the leaks,
but they didn't know about the DMs. That's what I was told. If
Nick knows about the DMs before this stream and Chud has proof
of that, Nick has lied a lot in public about this and probably
in private a lot, too.
Now, the intuition I had
back when Nick and I argued cuz that was the That was the critical
aspect of No, Augie doesn't say that Moody Morgan. He said earlier
they all knew some stuff about this that they were supposed to
shut up about, but that doesn't necessarily mean the Pixie DMs
and the Pixie text logs, right? Those logs are conclusive proof
undoubted Well, actually we have the Melina stuff. So, you could
say they knew anyway.
That's probably At this point I was like I had the personal opinion
that that stuff got leaked. Melina and Destiny had a super messy
divorce. I thought Melina might lean into that to just be like
you in a way that she could, right? I was friendly to Destiny,
way too way too charitable, way way way too charitable, okay?
But, that's what I thought that was.
I was unaware of other parties at that precise moment in time.
I want to claim this So, I'm I assume
cuz realistically, I do think it would be something of like a
nuke on Nicholas De Oreo if Chud could prove that Nick had these
DMs. Cuz at this point, I'm pretty confident that Nick has been
telling everybody
that he had no knowledge of the Pixie stuff, and this is how
Chud [__] them.
So, if that's not true, if it's not the case that Nick had no
knowledge of the Pixie DMs from Chud before this,
then Nick is at least telling a coherent story behind the scenes.
If Chud had proved that he had sent the Pixie DMs to Nick before
this, Nick's been lying to everybody about it, okay?
All of my thoughts were at >> I was thinking. I was like,
it's obvious
So, to go back, I'll just play this again because this is why
they think Chud [__] them is when Chud takes this
strong position, let's use our brains here. We know that they're
probably non-consensual, right? >> sharing of intimate
images because it's not being done for the intent, but it's still
bad to do it. >> You mean for the intent They're asking
if the participants in those videos were knowledgeable this was
being shared at all is the question. Yeah. And so, you can already
say because of the Molina stuff that it's non-consensual, right?
Non-consensually
I I saw it a different way. It's my personal relationship with
somebody, and I regret that, but that's how I saw it at the time.
And then I thought about it a little bit more,
and it just seemed like pretty obvious. So, I I I was pretty
convinced. Uh me and me and Queenin around this time we were
having a lot of conversations about whether or not it was. Neither
of us We were like the last people to find about these DMs and
the people who talked about this most by far. We talked about
this stuff on stream way more than anybody else. Like a thousand
times more than anybody else. We had roughly the same position
for like three or four
and we didn't know any of the actual
It's really [__] crazy.
No, Chud had the DMs. Chud had been Chud saw the DMs before this.
So, I don't know how the DMs the the leaks that Sunday eventually
got and Baked Alaska eventually got, Chud had those before this.
But, Nicholas and the rest of the people did not. Right. But,
>> Well, I doubt they were. I mean, I doubt they were.
That's what I was thinking. I was like, it's obvious that he
wasn't like, "Can I send your nudes to this other guy, by the
way?" Like, I don't think that was happening. Wait, were there
DMs? Were there DMs? >> Oh, we've got someone one of the
videos here, Tom. Tom, did he ask you about sending your sucking
dick to people or Well, I thought that was Nick Fuentes. Well,
you didn't ask I gave full permission, so I Dude, Tom is not
happy. Tom Tom is so transpa- Tom is not good at hiding his emotions
at all. I can't even see Tom's face, and you can hear how upset
Tom is that this is even being discussed and that Chud just made
that joke.
Even though that joke's just funny,
Uh you can hear that he's just pissed about it. Turkey Tom sent
the fans for confirmation. That being said, somebody before they
released the full video, I do have the full one I can send to
you for confirmation, Chud. Somebody edited my to look smaller
in the video,
>> Hey, um Tom, I have a question for you and it's about
>> So, Chud pushes Tom a little bit, but over like a joke
thing about the [__] dick-sucking video, right?
I have to read it. Uh Turkey Tom sent the fans want to know when
they're getting a Tom/Hawk Tuah Only Fans collab. Uh Tom is the
fans want to know when you're going to spit on that thing. Nick,
can you ask him? Hey, Tom's already pissed. >> What am
I supposed to say?
Dude, TOM'S SO PISSED, MAN. OH MY GOD.
oh, he cannot Dude, he doesn't take that pressure very well at
all.
>> Nick deflects. >> busy raising up Livestream
Dude, I I kind of I ruined my chat with my sense of humor, by
the way. I I destroyed my life, sorry. You talk about going to
Spirit. You're starting Galaxy outside of her house. I went to
Spirit Halloween and I bought a hawk to a hat for like $30 and
I forgot to wear it on stream. So wow, amazing. When do we talk
about more [__]
Wait, wait, Nick goes back to it. clip that we don't actually
engage in the
Okay. I mean, what are we supposed to say? We don't really know
what went on. Yeah, it's I guess that's kind of the main thing.
It's like I don't really >> Okay, so Nick goes back to
Now, if I remember correctly,
Chud doesn't let this go, does he? This is where Chud's like,
"No, I think we could reasonably say that
probably no consent there." Right? And I think Chud is using
as his pretext for this the Melina thing. Now, I I personally
feel bad about not having the Melina thing be my point where
I was like, "Obviously it's not consensual." And I'd asked Pixie
and she's just said, "I don't know what you're talking about.
That's on me. I know people are saying it's crazy or something,
right?" Like Pixie totally denied that it was even
And there was no Pixie like this before January 20th when she
comes out with the lawsuit. So at this time in my head, I'm like,
"I think Melina's angry and I don't know about the Pixie thing."
If I was not coping, I would see obviously Pixie wouldn't have
done that. If I was not coping, I'd say obviously there's a bunch
of women in here. It's unlikely that they'd do it. I wouldn't
have been but I was.
And so I think after some some conversations around this time
set me on more of like, "No, it's almost certainly not consensual
at all." And
like I probably I'm I'm I'm fine saying until Destiny like comes
out and comments that I assume that stuff wasn't consensually
released or consensually shared.
Okay? But Chud knows and that's what takes you from That's what
makes it difficult is a lot of people were ready to discount
Melina and it seems like Chud just stands on principle here,
but he knows. And I do wonder what would have happened cuz I
don't know I don't know what opinion Chud has on Melina. But
I wonder what would have happened if Chud didn't know know. do
it.
Back to a And then Tom says we can't say anything. I mean But
I I But to be fair, I went back and >> obvious It's pretty
Okay, okay, okay. Can we stop this sweeping please? And then
Chad goes in. It's pretty obvious what went on in there.
Then I'm screaming. Okay, this is the part where Chad goes in,
right? Where he's like, you guys are being
Dude, AUGIE'S JUST SCREAMING, "IT'S TOTAL DESTINY DEATH. IT'S
TOTAL DESTINY DEATH." over and over again as Chad SAYS THIS,
DUDE.
DUDE, HE SOUNDS LIKE A LITTLE KID.
THEN I'M SCREAMING. OKAY, this is the part where Chad goes in,
right? Where he's like, you guys are being And then I guess this
I pinged you with what Chad said the timeline was. Oh, okay.
This is what I thought it was. What's the What's the timestamp
on this, Qualia? Can you tell me?
Cuz now I actually think I got lied to. Unless this got changed.
I think I got lied to for the purpose of like winning a debate
that I think I was correct on the whole time.
Before December 30th stream, I get told about the stuff happening
with Pixie. I tell Nick Nicholas verbally about it in a call.
As in, Nicholas knows, okay. So, I am correct. Nicholas knows.
I should have just stood on this cuz I I thought, "Hey, if I
like de-escalate this with Nick, we're going to be cool." Not
Not true. Didn't happen, okay?
Cuz Nick told me explicitly, "I had no idea about this stuff
before."
So, if Chad's telling the truth here, maybe we get a clarification
or something, okay?
But it sure sounds like
knew about the Pixie non-consensual
before this, and Tom didn't, right? So, that's what you I assume
So, Chad and Nick both know.
And Chad told Nick. They both know they So, that's the context
you need for this call is Chad and Nick both know.
They both know the other one knows. Tom doesn't know. So, Tom
is kind of getting [__] here because he is probably
in a similar position to the one I was in where he's like willing
to discount Molina because he's heard really bad things about
Molina for a very long time, right? Now, you might not feel especially
in retrospect, you might not
any amount of charity for that or could care for that at all.
That's fine. You don't have to. I'm just explaining to you why
Tom would take like a position in the other direction and then
we can be kind of evaluate the Chud and the Nick reactions for
this. >> I guess that's kind of the main thing is I don't
really know what to do. >> Nick goes back to it. So, I
could see
Just think of this as a little thing between Nick and Chud here,
right? Where Nick is willing to go with like Tom's whole sweep
thing.
and Chud comes in probably knowing that Nick like he probably
sees Nick doing this and he's like, "Dude, I told you about this
already. Like, what are you doing? You know it wasn't like this.
You know we know. You know that it is
I would Oh, dude, I wonder if they had the conversation. It's
like cuz in in my mind, if I were Chud here,
I do this sometimes, okay? I do this sometimes. And you guys
will never know about it cuz I'll never talk about it. But sometimes
if I know something,
I know know something, I will make the argument that this is
definitely the case and I will use a piece of evidence that really
supports it strongly but probably isn't proof. And I'll say it's
enough for me, right? So, I might know something to be true and
I could argue it knowing that I like know it in confidence somehow.
But if I could make the argument from a different piece of evidence,
I would just do that, right?
I think that's probably what Chud's doing here is he'll he knows
that there's non-consensual stuff shared for a fact and that
somebody is upset about it and pursuing something over it.
But he's going to go to the Molina thing, which everybody knows.
Back to a and then Tom says we can't say anything. I mean but
I but to be fair, I went back and I was like, "Okay, it's pretty
obvious Okay, okay, can we stop this sweeping, please?" >> And
then Chud goes in. >> It's pretty obvious what went on
in there. debate. okay. Well, see, you know what? No, no, no,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
IT'S [__] OBVIOUS, DUDE. >> THEN I'M SCREAMING.
OKAY, this is the part where Shud goes in, right? Where he's
like, "You guys are
I don't know what Augie knew.
Moody Morgan, Augie said something that's unless you know of
a timestamp later here cuz I saw you in the chat. I heard what
Augie said before this.
You have to understand, they would consider knowledge from Kiwi
Farms that they're kind of keeping private out of respect for
the victims. Everybody was doing this at the time
that they were trying to, out of respect for the victims, not
talk about it, not name them, not really say much other than
I guess Destiny Shud got leaked.
So, that's That's like the thing they're not supposed to mention
is any of the victims' names, anything like that. >> [__]
And then I guess this is the part where Tom and Nick are like,
"This
because we can't talk about this." Dude. And then you jumped
on old Destiny death immediately. Here's the thing. I knew that
we couldn't, obviously, explain ourselves, explain why
we know Destiny at this point is like a piece of [__]
But I wasn't going to pretend like I didn't think he was a piece
of [__] If somebody asked me why, I just feel like,
"Uh, he sucks, dude." But I wouldn't I don't just because I I
can't explain why Dude, is there any way Do we have this debate
with me and Nick? It would kill me to watch this debate cuz I
know [clears throat] I took a knee when I when I was pretty sure
I was correct. It would kill me to watch it, okay? Taking a knee
to this like fat It would piss me off, but I'm almost positive
if you have this as a fact, if he knew this at the time, which
now the Shud screenshots, which I was pretty sure I'd seen these
logs or something, if I if he knew this at the time, then I think
I took a knee in this debate and he was just trying to sweep.
And I'm I'm even more pissed at myself. >> Why? It doesn't
mean that that's not going to be my take. I'm not going to sit
here and pretend like he's cool or I don't know. I'll just be
like Show the chat I was vindicated with time. I don't show the
chat too. I don't
I don't know if I can find it or somebody will. No, he's he's
not saying somebody asked me why then I'll be like
And lots of stuff from around here is like lost media. It's not
uploaded anywhere, so Don't worry about it, dude. I'm lucky.
>> is. All right, Adam to the call. Bring him in. >> logic,
let's talk about it. Chud logic, let's talk about it. >> Okay,
so then Tom bites >> you mean it's obvious? Melina commented
on it. So I I DON'T TRUST MELINA.
HOLD ON. ISN'T it talk about Melina which is separate from at
least I think that's separate from like the uh the Pixie stuff.
So I went on the Melina >> know Melina. [laughter] Okay,
well well okay, I'll tell you what. If she's lying, what doesn't
Destiny prove it
I don't know. That's why I said I'm waiting to see if you're
lying or not. >> Why did he react Why Why is he not commenting
on it in any meaningful way? It's obvious what's going on. I
went on Why is he sweeping? It's unbelievable. I'd heard it,
but I didn't know it was true. Here we go. Here we go. Here we
go. Here we go. Here we go. Here we go. Here we go. Here we go.
Here we go. Here we go. Here we go. Here we go. Here we All right.
Here we go. I went on Okay, my my Okay, hold on. Let me talk
to Chud real quick. Okay. Here we go. Okay. So for
So if if if if if Nicholas knew
and Chud knew
I I do agree with people that I I don't think it's likely that
that Nick Oh, hold on.
I I I'll just ask Augie. I'll just ask Augie directly.
Okay. All right. She could be telling the truth. For Destiny,
that clip does look bad, but I've been traumatized by the internet
by the amount of false allegations that have happened that I'm
just waiting. Okay? What happens when someone's levy is a false
allegation? The person at the center of the allegation responds
and debunks it, right? Yeah, he hasn't responded yet. >> So why
isn't that happened?
I don't know yet. All right. Just be
At this point at this point it's literally been a month. And
I do think Tom had distanced at this point, hadn't he? Didn't
Tom around the time the leaks happened? I think before you even
get to December, Turkey Tom distances from Destiny, right?
Am I crazy?
Tom DG. Tom cutting ties for a while.
This is What is the date?
December 2nd. So, this is 4 weeks before the stream, Tom cuts
So, Tom went to the election stream.
Tom was cool, chill for the month of November, and then December,
Tom cuts ties. The show is away from responding to controversy.
All right, but >> No, but he usually does wait. So, the
clip from >> For what? The thing is The thing is, based
on everything I've seen, I think you're probably right, but I'm
not going to go To be fair, though, it is even though it is uh
total Destiny death, I agree generally with Chud. Tom getting
false allegations like a year later is interesting irony.
Oh, you agree generally with Tom, I mean. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What did Chud do wrong here? Well, see, that's the thing, right?
I don't necessarily think
I mean, I think Chud's coming It depends on what they know. I
think uh How do I put this? It It really depends on what Nicholas
knows and what Tom knows. If neither of them know,
I am of the opinion that there's something going on here. There's
a little thought
Chud knows for sure, and he can speak with certainty.
I think given you have hidden information, possibly, that lets
you speak with a certainty, I think you probably chill a little
bit on trying to like press Tom super hard.
Right? But, if Tom and and Nick both knew, then I don't really
think there's something super wrong going on here because they
are trying to go against that thing they know in private, and
that actually looks really bad for them. I mean, added a little
too strong because he's like, "Well, we know Melina said." And
Tom's just saying, "Well, we can't take Melina's word as a 100%
fact." Which, by the way, even still to this day,
do do we know if Destiny 100% sent Melina's nudes to other people
without Was that in the leaks? I don't even know. It probably
was, but I mean I don't even
I mean, her stuff was sent and she said it was up without consent.
I think Aki maybe just doesn't know the facts here. Like do we
know? We do know. If he has inside knowledge that Destiny is
bad, why is he openly lying and saying we got to wait? I don't
know yet.
Well, he's saying we got to wait for At this time we didn't know
[__] about Melina. We only knew about No, you you
know no.
Oh,
no.
What Moody Morgan? I had a I had a talk with Nick here. And Nick
came in and he was super heated cuz me and Aiden were talking
and I was like, "Oh, obviously this looks bad for them. Obviously
they're saying stupid [__] here and obviously they
can't blame Chud for it." I was arguing that. Me and Aiden talked
about it. I was kind of debate him cuz I was an [__]
Okay? I was being really mean. I was talking over him and and
like blood sporting him.
I didn't really care about the topic. I was like, "I don't care
to like litigate this." But Aiden wanted to debate me on it and
so he joined and he got completely debate wrecked. And then Nicholas
joined and he was fuming cuz I was basically arguing that he
looked like a a piece of [__] here. But I was like,
"I didn't I told Aiden before we talked, I don't want to have
this debate because I think I even I think it was the same thing.
I think I took donations for it. I'm like, "I don't want to have
this debate because personally I don't want to like dick off
iced. I'm whatever, we'll figure out what goes on there later,
okay?" And then we started talking and I'm pretty sure the thing
that made Nick like win this debate with me was he was like,
"No, I didn't have any of those DMs before this."
No, I I didn't have any of those DMs. I didn't have any of that
knowledge. And if he had that knowledge and he just lied to me,
then he's a total piece of [__] I mean, I already
thought he was a total piece of [__] now, but would
have been [__] up, man.
And we're talking about a different situation. So, that's probably
why he said we got to wait.
Melina actually literally you're Tom is literally referring Augie's
just wrong here. Tom's literally referring to Melina's post,
Melina's stream where she she says none of that was consensual.
That's Augie's literally referring to Melina's stream. Sorry,
Tom is referring to that. That's what he's saying false allegations
cuz Melina has made an allegation and so Tom's talking about
false allegations because Melina has made an allegation. Now,
obviously one can infer that if you know that he sent Pixie's
nudes without her consent to other people
then he It sure sounds to me like Augie is saying they all knew
about Augie knew about the Pixie stuff 100%. It sure sounds that
way, Moody Morgan. It does. >> He probably did the same
thing to Melina, but you can't say that for sure,
And I he's kind of giving it away. >> if He's kind of giving
it away because he's like, "Oh, obviously we knew about the Pixie
thing." >> The inside knowledge also involves victims that
don't want it public,
Oh, I don't have a way to cast judgment. I don't know. Yeah,
bro. I'm not saying you have to do a whole full thing about it.
I get that, right? But like, can we stop at all how It's obvious.
It's obvious, okay? It's very clear. >> Okay. Okay, but
but the problem to me is like you say it's obvious and like I
think it probably is that way if I had to guess, but I just don't
know. I Bro, somebody find me that. It's got to be on Aiden's
channel somewhere, right? I I feel like Aiden was streaming during
that. It's got to be on Aiden's channel >> I I don't know
the people involved. I don't necessarily trust Melina, okay?
Tom even says it's probably that way, but he doesn't know. That's
like a completely fair take. >> thing, please. I So, the
problem that I have with that one video with the Melina stuff
is I went back cuz I didn't Oh, and this is the other thing that
was total cope. The idea that this could be about Leafy, Melina
talking about Leafy is such
psycho babble. It doesn't deserve to be given a like a coherent
response. It's It's so stupid. That's One of them says it's like
oh, she's maybe talking about
Bro, I'm trust a random Reddit post with a 30-second clip that
was clipped from multiple live streams. So, I went back and I
down The problem here is this conversation is all about Melina,
which we didn't know really [__] about. The only
thing we knew about was Pixie, but obviously no It's funny that
if you just let the video play, he'd realize that no, you know
a lot of [__] about Melina. You know exactly about
Melina. >> talk about Pixie >> here because It's
what they're referring >> in like the discourse at the
time, except in private. This mindset helps the infant cycle.
Downloaded the full context to every single clip that was used.
So, I have like a 2-minute version of every 15-second clip. >> clip
from her stream that was posted to Reddit? There was
three different live streams that were posted to Reddit. I'm
mainly going back to listen to this to hear if Chud was being
like super [__] weird here. Clip with If If Chud
Honestly, if Chud told these guys and Chud had some idea that
they all knew, and they were still saying this [__]
I think Chud was calm and kind to them.
If Chud had the impression that only Nick knew and Tom didn't,
I think I could infer that Chud was kind of being a dick to Tom.
If he had some sort of
But Augie now is saying we all knew about the Pixie thing. So,
now I'm like confused and I I'm trying to resolve the timeline
in my head cuz I That That basically is how you answer it, right?
You guys see the the state machine in my mind? That like if If
Chud knows, I do feel like that's a dick move to do to your friend.
You know something for a fact, he doesn't know it, you can't
tell him, and then he kind of is hesitant to agree with you on
it, and you just like go hard on him. Let's stop the [__]
sweeping, man. What the [__] are you talking about?
Right? I think there's there's a reason you could be mad if you're
that friend. Like hey, you could be a little gentle if you knew
that like I have a bias and knew that I don't have the same information
you had. I think that's fair.
Could you end a friendship over it? That would also be insane.
>> was cut up from like six different points into the stream
and stitched together. So, like the people are pointing to one
clip where she goes, "That's not consensual.
Um and we're not going to talk about that. I'm going to ban you."
In context with all the other
it sounded like to me for that one specific clip, she was referring
to the stuff from the Leafy thing where people had revenge porn
of her or whatever or like concept of it. >> is completely
stupid by Nick because obviously nobody was When the Malena stuff
came out, nobody was talking about, "Oh, maybe they're talking
about Leafy like when Leafy showed her nudes." This point is
just completely actually her and it was being shared around.
I That's what I got from that. But people were connecting that
clip to the other clip. That's This is what I've been trying
to I I wasn't sure, so I think Malena >> I'm pretty sure
this actually was sweeping. This was so stupid. I almost said
that, but I don't want to say that. All right, I don't think
Nick was intentionally sweeping, but this point was just completely
I was just going to say 100% it was. Yeah, I'm not going to say
I'm not going to go that far, but this was a ridiculous point.
Uh This might have been what like totally soured me in a lot
of ways and like like I would I was pretty annoyed about this.
When I heard this in Nick's stream, I was like, "Bro, it's crazy
that Nick is saying this." Maybe he saw that coverage. Maybe
that's why he was so pissed at me. I'm like, "This is a [__]
insane thing to say." It's a totally insane thing to say
Nick's argument for why this was the case was nobody else had
looked at the context. But I, being the totally fair and neutral
arbiter that I am, I'd gone to Malena's stream, downloaded the
whole thing, and listened to like 30 minutes of the stream. I
watched the whole stream basically.
Like I watched huge chunks of that stream. It was undeniable
what they were talking about. Um bottle sucker with the 500 kicks.
Have you seen the wood chipper Nick vid? What about the helicopter?
The dude has people who want him dead. I did see the wood [laughter]
chip
Chud said after he was one of the only people who didn't know
about the DMs, but I'm gullible. The wood chipper one was my
community made that. Pretty sure Sponda made that [__]
She should give a more clear and concise statement if she wants
to even put this thing out. That's the other thing. >> It's kind
of interesting cuz that's one of the things that I had um >> Wait,
that's a lie. I saw it on Sponda's account. Maybe he just reposted
it. I made it. I have the proof. Okay.
argue with Destiny about one of the the first time we had we
actually had like a real argument cuz I wanted to stream a few
times and it was kind of friendly. But then we had like some
conversation about Leafy where Leafy had made some he had done
some stream where he had shown some I don't know if >> Okay,
the fact that Leafy was even brought up is actually just completely
cancerous for this discourse in this stream. a full nude picture
of Melina or what it was. Um and >> the Yeah, I think this
is what we're talking about. Yeah, that one. >> Yeah, yeah.
And he was and he was like
Phil Cole was right to all along.
Phil Cole? Thank you for the $3 man. making fun of it. And I
was like, yeah, that's but I don't know if I would call it revenge
porn. >> actually have this clip queued up if you want
to hear it cuz it's in I have my my stream document. >> The
clip of her? I have I have all
I mean this did happen. But it's totally worthless to say it
Cuz something did happen that Melina was directly referring to,
directly talking about her trauma from past relationships, directly
referring to her past marriage like like she was it was painfully
obvious she was referring specifically to the Destiny leaks that
happened. all the clips of her talking about it, but I have that
specific one. I think I can grab it. Do you want to just screen
share it, yeah? Like I don't even understand how Leafy even came
up in this conversation because Melina was talking about Because
Melina leak had her nudes leaked by Leafy. >> Yeah, he
shared my [__] without my consent. It sucked. How
would Leafy even enter the discourse? All Leafy did was just
look up public nudes. Unless the argument is that that those
weren't public nudes, those were nudes that Destiny leaked of
her that I guess she was fine with for some reason even though
they were dating at the time or married and then Leafy pulled
them up. It doesn't even make any [__] sense,
Uh yeah, let me see if So this is a clip if we're talking about
Leafy or talking about Destiny. >> is this is all I have
every clip that she's recently made talking about They were paywalled
I'm pretty sure so leaking without consent would have to be like
a paywalled argument. Yeah, I mean the fact that Leafy's even
in this discourse is just [__] actual cancer. about
Destiny cuz I went back and I got all of them cuz I was planning
on doing a segment and I just wanted to wait and see if there's
anything else before I do it. Uh I see. So let me screen share.
Cuz it again these the clip was taken that like this there's
a 30-second clip that's on all the things that or like a 2-minute
clip that's being shared around and the 30-second clip the 30-second
one I think was clipped with two different things and the longer
one is like four different [__] segments across multiple
streams. So I had to become a [__] member to go find
and hear what she actually said.
I'm just kidding. Man. All right, you ready? I mean the thing
is this is only one person though. So so what you'd have to believe
is that every single person whose video was sent consented to
it, right? Now obviously there's some discussion and you know
not non-certainty over who certain people are and saying it makes
it clear who that is and maybe they've not confirmed it's them
so it's a bit complicated. >> What do you mean by What
do you mean by The reality is I do not believe every single Sorry,
go on. What do you mean by all the different people?
Well, there's obviously multiple clips of different people having
different clips happening, right? The easiest one to reference
is the guy who's was getting sucked. Oh, okay. >> Yeah,
and which again I just just to be clear I agree with everything
you're >> that the guy Okay, this is very simple this is
very simple. This is very simple. Stop Tom. Your explicit sweeping
attempts are so [__] NOT JUSTIFIED.
SHUT THE [__] UP, OKAY? I CAN'T TELL IF YOU'RE ACTUALLY
TROLLING. THIS SWEEPING ME ASKING A [__] LISTEN,
put the broom down and listen. Simple question. Do you think
every single person whose video got shared said, "Yes, I'm happy
for that to be sent to some Do you Do you see how like Do you
guys see what I'm saying? I I don't think I've I've an audience
such that I don't think there's any charity they'd give to Tom.
But do you see what I'm saying that Chud knows knows and if Tom
doesn't know know that like there is he's going pretty hard on
a guy who's like clearly close friends with Destiny
doesn't have the same level of
Right? some random person in the future I don't even know. Do
you think that
If I had to guess, probably not. But it's also Destiny who's
a freak and has a very strange life and does a lot of weird stuff.
So who knows? If they're already each other, is it unreasonable
He's like a crazy gooner, guys.
Well, for me, too. Or sorry. If they're If Milena and Destiny
are [__] each other and they're [__]
all these random people, okay? And who knows who else is involved,
okay? Is it unreasonable for me to assume that they would also
be like, "When she When she Doesn't she have an only fans or
fansly?" Is it unreasonable for me to be like, "Well, I have
no idea. Don't they send to everyone?" I wouldn't be shocked
by that. >> the kind of material that was being shared
is the kind of stuff she would post to a fansly account.
I don't know what was on her fansly. Isn't fansly before?
Isn't that her whole thing is that she doesn't do full nudes?
Any full nudes that existed were revenge Wasn't that her claim?
Is that what she said? I'm pretty sure that's her claim. That
was her claim Leafy, right?
Back when But I thought the claim was with Leafy was the problem
was that it was like a nude that was leaked but it wasn't a nude
that was leaked from the fansly or something. It was a nude that
was leaked like from some person who leaked it without her consent
and then he showed it later. All right. I think that we're getting
in a We're caught in a thing here. Tom, you need to concede that
it's reasonable to assume that there's like a I said that. >> to
get absolute like Before we come to any conclusion, we need to
know whether these things were shared with consent of all parties.
It's reasonable to call out allegations on the table. There's
no thing that's been slapped down that is this person has done
the same thing to other people. >> did. That's why we're
playing the clip. I want to know if you guys have it. >> it's
like a comment on a stream or something. Play it. Have you got
it lined up? I'll join it now. Yeah. I don't really hear what
Chud is being like totally inappropriate here, right? He's pushed
I think man, maybe I'm just being too charitable to Tom. I do
think
I think Tom's saying stupid [__] now. Like Tom, unfortunately
Tom got pressed and now he's saying really really
And he has been saying really really The original press is what
I'm more like, oh, let's stop the sweeping.
Just admit that it's like reasonable to assume. I think that
was it's easier to assume that when you know. >> obviously,
but he's making the same like pushback I would have done
maybe if Chud wasn't in this conversation
because it's they're reasonable questions. He's not holding like
information over Tom's head that he knows that we're not allowed
to talk about unless I'm missing something here,
Well, cuz I'm only bringing up the Molina thing cuz this is the
only thing
>> Chud got baited into differentiating himself from totally
opinions.
I think that's true.
And I'm I'm hearing now, okay, I I asked I'm hearing now that
it was not from Chud that they would have gotten that knowledge.
So, that's what we were thinking was it was from Chud with these
DMs, but this may be incorrect. This seems to be incorrect that
there's this call is conflated with like it actually happens
right after this, okay?
So, right after this, it's uh Yeah, it's right after the December
30th stream, apparently. This timeline's a little shuffled. So,
I don't know that they didn't know, but it the thing I thought
was that basically this were the case this was the case. I think
this first part gets a little shuffled.
We continue. We continue. Where's my kick streamer? I'm speaking
up. I'm going to die. Okay, just play it. Okay, I got to figure
out if this is the right one. I'll try to save you one sec.
So then I would say that everything after that initial press
I'm kind of okay with, right? I'm more or less okay with.
I do think they say a lot of things.
That original press of like you're definitely sweeping Tom, what
the [__] I think that was pretty aggressive if Tom
didn't know if he didn't know
But it's certainly not enough to end a friendship over.
Do you have a screenshot of it? Yeah. I think they have I'll
be real.
Tom is a thousand times more bitter by the way. Not about being
called getting called a sweeper or anything. It's just the disrespect,
right?
It's just the disrespect. Like I I think it's the way Chud spoke.
Put the broom down. Put the broom down. I think that's it's the
tone that's he's that he's upset about or Nick would be upset
about more than anything else. I've been on that journey to learn
from men. Yeah, exactly.
I will say though I don't really understand how Tom is sweeping
here because it's like
Tom's basically saying like I mean he's being like way too charitable
and like naive to Destiny's position, right? Where he's like
oh, you know, maybe it was fine or whatever. Obviously at this
point it's like yeah, this guy's right? But Tom is just playing
it ultra
Chud screaming that he's a sweeper. It's like I can see how from
Tom's perspective that's completely totally annoying, but I don't
really see any
No. No. No.
Tom couldn't be accused of being a sweeping or couldn't accused
of
Sorry, it's late. Tom couldn't be accused of sweeping if he just
said, "I'm going to withhold my statement, my opinion until more
information comes
When there is a victim who's made an allegation and then he says,
"Well, I don't know. She kind of does And also like they're kind
of all And do we really know for sure that like she couldn't
have just said okay and now she's making a false allegation?"
That is explicitly sweeping. That is explicitly sweeping, Augie.
Call it like it is. That's sweeping.
obviously sweeping. Playing it safe is saying, "I'mma shut my
mouth." That's That's not sweeping. Nobody has ever accused someone
of being a sweeper when there's a situation where there's some
ambiguity and you just don't want to bring it up.
Yeah, where there's true ambiguity in anyway. Uh I don't know.
Listen, you would have all been safer if you just not spoken
about it, okay?
No, it's not a 24-hour stream. I just keep streaming cuz I am
interested in this and I would have to log off or whatever to
I would just be watching this if I logged off. like dirty or
foul play going on here from Chud's side. Maybe he's being annoying
or obnoxious or aggressive, you could say. But I don't really
see how foul play is
Mhm. Exactly. I think I don't know if No, it's it's just sweeping
because Melina is saying explicitly that's not Well, I actually
don't recall what Melina said up to this point, but the clips
are She says this without hesitation. Coming as somebody that
was a participant of this call that knew the same things that
they knew.
Uh this is like from my perspective, I was in the same position
as all three of these other guys were and a participant of this
conversation. I don't remember this call being cancerous.
And I'm listening to it right now just to re-familiarize myself
with it. It doesn't really seem that bad.
one, but she talks about it in multiple I hope one day that I
can
I don't know. I don't even know if details of anything is really
that important. But I'm pretty sure Now, this is Nick sounds
totally reasonable here. I mean, I don't really hear bad foul
play from anyone. I mean, the Leafy
Tom is totally being Tom said a thousand things.
Brother, come on. Come on, brother.
Bringing up Leafy's cancer, but other than that like it just
seems like a regular conversation.
Tom's take seems
Malfoy chuds being reasonable. I'm not really saying anything
here. I haven't heard it. Cuz we're doing a lot of pausing. I
don't think I say anything much at all in this conversation until
the end. And yeah, it doesn't really seem like that crazy of
a conversation is happening here. The first one. This is is it?
The not this one. Maybe this one. Um but then I just prioritize
more creative work. So if I'm going to do an important audition,
I'll take time to learn the script.
You know you know what I did? Um I don't want to say too much
about it obviously.
But I Um I also like contacted
a friend that has the same job as the character that I auditioned
for. So I like was really cool so I had to do that. Then I also
went to therapy. >> I will say though, one thing that's
funny about this call, I'm not really getting the vibe that anyone
in here doesn't want to talk about Destiny other than maybe Tom.
Everyone else like even Nick seems excited. He's got clips ready
to go. Like it seems like there even though there was this whole
thing like let's just not cover this dude.
Even Nick seems ready to go.
>> It's kind of crazy. You're all itching to talk about
it. Yeah.
I'm pretty sure in private we talked about this with Nick too.
I can't remember if it was before or after this. I want to say
it was after
It's great my character. Cuz I think I think I saw this and when
he came in I'm like bro you know you know that was >> this
is the therapy one. And this whole Well I definitely wanted to
talk about it. I wanted it talked about weeks before it was talked
about until brave patriot present Sunday. Just
Um until present Sunday finally leaked But yeah. We're together.
Be like oh yeah. This community is so fun.
What kind of stuff would this person feel and think about something
like this happening to them? blah blah blah. So we were like
me and my therapist were just psychoanalyzing this character.
>> I'm talking about that present Sunday sucks. But yeah,
you know what I mean.
so that I can do it as good as possible.
No. What's she talking about here? Uh this is with one of the
therapy clips. I pulled out like anything that was even clipped.
I pulled the full context for.
Let me see. Is it
It was really nice. It was really really nice. No. Is it this
one? There's just so many clips.
I'm trying to take it easy. I needed to. Like some There was
an incident that happened that was No, that's not it.
Okay, that was the first one. And I tried something called um
EMDR.
Have you guys ever heard of it?
The [__] is this then? [clears throat] It's this
one. Yeah. That was really horrible. Actually really horrible.
>> This is cancerous.
Yeah. That's like actual revenge
Um so no, thank you. It's it's not anything like that. So so
thank you. That's something else. >> This is a recent clip
of her talking about whatever's going on. This is 9 days ago.
But this is either her talking about Destiny's leaks or >> This
is her talking about Destiny leaking a guy or like
Yeah. Well, cuz no, cuz the revenge porn from the leafy stuff.
It's not like I don't know which one she's talking >> feel
like I feel like the way to figure it out would be to see what
the chatter was saying. It's just the Destiny stuff. I think
I might have even looked at the chatter in the I might have even
looked at her logs. It was definitely the Destiny stuff.
I don't think she's calling the Destiny thing revenge. I think
she's saying it's not like something that was mentioned in the
chat that was revenge porn. I I >> deleted the master so
maybe she wasn't >> But this this is getting I'm saying
but this is getting compart Yeah, this this is the archive of
the vod. The chatter was By the way, I'm about to go down next
to this abomination of a guy. >> [__] [__]
[__] Yeah, bro. I think I'm live. Oh my [__]
god dude. So I didn't know what this was cuz they cut this and
they'll put it next to those other clips of her talking about
Destiny and saying she's going to therapy and I'm not sure if
this is in reference to like the known revenge thing cuz I don't
know was Melina in the leaks?
From what I Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, I think she was. Yeah. >> I think so.
I don't know. So this is Yeah, this is a >> believe so.
It's it's not anything like that so thank you. That's something
also that happened. Um yeah. That was really horrible. Actually
really horrible. I take that very
Uh so anyone commenting about that stuff By the way random question
but is Melina still with Meme Troll?
>> Is she still with the baby Meme Troll? Is that still
happening? I'm curious. Whatever happened to her?
experience. They're going to be Uh as far as I know Melina dates
somebody from the There's like a Swedish acting royalty family,
Skarsgards.
She dates like the the like the least successful son in that
family who also does like TV in Sweden and I think she just I
I think I just got told that she just got like a a real part
in a real Swedish TV show. Like she's gone into acting and I
think she just got a real part for the first time like a real
substantial part of some kind. That was the last I heard. They're
going to get instantly banned and never >> Wasn't that
his name? I can't even remember that was his [__]
name, Meme Troll. So she's just saying she's never going to make
a real It's like gay Swedish guy. claim about it. And then why
do you think that is? Why do you think [clears throat] Melina
is a bit a bit shy about making comments on it? I mean she she
doesn't seem >> shy about it though cuz she's talked about
it like three of her last It's that but she also just said why
she said it's traumatic, right? That too.
Yeah, sure but you know, you understand that when her and Destiny
split up you made a content like basically misrepresenting the
reason for their relationship ending without mentioning the Lauren
Southern stuff, which was a big reason for that happening. Yes,
I do understand that 1000%. >> Right. So So Once again,
I understand her perspective and why she wouldn't want to do
that. Um but, you know, for >> question is though why say
anything at
Why say anything at all? Well, cuz she wants people to stop berating
her in her chat, no? Then if you want her to stop, then you shouldn't
talk about it and you should ban the thing and remove words.
>> I mean, I agree but
Isn't it sweep sweep and Nick striking again now? Look at this.
My god, that [__] is so cancerous with the sweeping
[__]
I understand that the frustration here, I mean, at this point
[laughter] it literally is like sweeping. Like it is it's totally
sweeping. >> he just gets so off with the [__]
sweeping allegations. So aids. The Melina listen >> He's
right. Yeah. I'm arguing that trigger word? Yes, it is. It's
a [__] trigger word. You know how
mentally damaged that word has made me?
It's not cool to joke about that. He wants to let people to know
about it. That's why he's talking. >> thing that's interesting
though is even Nick is pushing Tom here. Even Nick is like nudging
Tom in this conversation.
And again Chud was right. Hold on. Chud was right, but Chud knows
he's right and I do believe none of the rest of them know. Unless
there's unless there's other evidence that comes out, I believe
none of the rest of them knew.
So there is a difference between like no
and being forceful about it and like knowing. And I
I can almost understand somebody feeling weird about it even.
You know what I mean? No, hold on. What they So they're arguing
over the Melina thing and I do think they're like the Melina
stuff, there really is no excuse for Melina going it it was non-consensual
and they're like arguing over well, we don't know. We don't really
know. And like should Melina even be talking about
Um Chud wouldn't have said that if he'd seen all the clips. I
don't I still believe they've not gotten to the actual
The actual clip makes it very obvious.
You can't really contextualize your way out of it. It's obvious
what she was talking about. I know for a fact what she was talking
about. Right? I believe that we know that for a fact cuz Kelly
was talking to her. Kelly knew what she was talking about, right?
Kelly knew that it was non-consensual. It's like it's absolutely
not a question that for Melina the stuff was non-consensual and
trying to make it like her fault or trying to talk about whose
fault it could be. It No.
Like she has the allegation that it's
You got to bite the bullet and say, "I don't trust Melina for
X reason."
I'm pretty sure we all know the same [__] In fact,
I might know the least, Chud might know the most, but I think
we were all pretty much on equal footing here when it comes to
like things we knew versus things that we didn't know. Chud probably
knew the most though. If I have to remember. talking about it.
Yeah, she Yeah, she put it out there in a way where she can let
people know, but not totally address But but at the same time,
like how many people have we covered on stream who don't want
something to be talked about and talk about it anyway, you know?
Like nobody Nobody actually >> Yeah, but none of them are
like
Nobody None of them are like Destiny's ex-wife and like [snorts]
Now Now Nick's basically telling Sorry, now Tom's basically telling
Nick to stop sweeping.
political stream I I You know what I mean? Like this is like
a We talk about little
to say stuff like that. >> Well, is there any charge that
could be pressed if that's true?
No, but it's Maybe. Yeah, potentially, but that's not why I'm
talking I'm talking about it more of a moral issue.
Right? Like even if it's not
distribute it with malice, which I don't know if depending what
state if that even matters or not. To be clear, I'm not To be
clear, I'm not saying that it's a distinction between legality
and morality. I'm just curious if there's a charge you can press
if that's true. I know Queen Queen is going to say that I'm a
really really crazy based person here who's giving the best takes
possible, but I really think that you ought not distribute
to people without their consent. I know, it's a brave take from
Nick Diiorio, but Wow, it's crazy to think back to a time where
he wasn't scared to say that name. That's nuts. >> Well,
if that is The thing is is like revenge porn wasn't a thing at
the time. So, you need to be doing it specifically with the intent
of like shaming or harassing them in some way, right? But just
because the intent isn't there doesn't mean something wrong isn't
happened. And that's why I think there's this thing of like non-consensual
distribution of intimate images
because it strips away the
the intent aspect. >> you telling me there's there's no
law there's no law that prevents you from
sending porn someone that they gave to you in confidence to someone
else? Well, no, I'm saying that there is, but I don't know I
think from what I've read about it I think it's a civil issue.
But, you know, I don't know loads about it. That's like my bit.
Non-lawyer take. Why can't I not jump over this barrier? Okay,
so you can jump over everything except for the things you can't
jump. Is that pretty much it? I'm not really hearing anything
that's cancerous here that Chad is like doing that's super AIDS.
It seems like this was a pretty relatively normal discussion
from everybody.
I mean, I'm not even really hearing anything objectionable by
anyone in this
It just seems like a regular conversation. So,
I don't know. It's really not. It's really not at all. Is that
pretty much it? I mean, I can listen to more of this, but I think
you get the [__]
Let's go back.
I thought that was funny to listen to just Augie going through
that call cuz I remember some of it. And I got to ask Chad about
something and get that litigated. So, without further ado, I'm
probably going to head out for the night, guys. It's pretty late.
It's pretty late.
And we went an hour over, so